in an effort to determine the
vulnerability of coastal installations
bw attack from offshore
tests were held recently at a large air
base
the site selected was ideally suited to
a test of this nature
located on the coast this vital military
installation is bordered by water on two
sides
two men ostensibly on a fishing trip
arranged to rent a small outboard
motorboat
after receiving instructions in
operating the boat the fishermen cast
off
once out of sight of the pier
they made for an isolated spot on the
shore
here a disseminating device filled with
a harmless bw agent was put on the boat
the disseminating device and its power
source were concealed under a tarpaulin
then the men began an apparently aimless
cruise up the bayou toward the air base
with weather conditions favorable the
men began to spray the dry simulate
agent across the path of a gentle wind
blowing toward the air base
spraying was continuous while the boat
traveled a distance of one and a half
miles
in the immediate vicinity of the boat
the cloud of biological organisms could
not be distinguished from the exhaust
smoke of the motor
and it rapidly became invisible as it
drifted downwind
the wind of about three to six miles per
hour carried the cloud of simulant agent
over most of the operations area
administrative area and base housing
and continued in high concentration
several miles
beyond at no time during the operation
were the men challenged
questioned
or even suspected of being other than
fishermen
certainly there was no outward
indication that the air base was the
target of a biological warfare attack
had this been an actual attack with an
infectious agent
a tremendous patient load would have
been imposed on the medical facilities
the operations of the base would have
been seriously hampered or possibly even
completely disrupted
in another test a similar type of
disseminating device loaded with
simulant agent was fitted into the
luggage compartment of an automobile and
connected to the exhaust pipe of the car
the operating controls of the unit were
placed on the front seat so that the
driver could easily start and stop the
dissemination and vary the rate of
output to suit the speed of the car
driven along a public road upwind of the
air base the vehicle appeared no
different from any other car with a
slightly smoky exhaust
no one paid any attention to the car the
driver or to the exhaust
which in fact was a bw aerosol drifting
toward the air base
applying the results of this test to a
large densely populated city such as
washington
the tremendous casualty producing
potential of biological warfare becomes
frightening
and it would be so easy to contaminate
the air with infectious organisms
these disseminating devices were merely
jury rigged affairs easily duplicated
with parts obtainable in any city
at the u.s army chemical corps proving
ground tests were conducted using an
f-100 aircraft equipped with an
experimental spray device developed by
one of the large aviation companies
one purpose of these tests was to
establish the feasibility of producing
bw aerosols in the most effective
particle size range
as a low-level line source from
high-speed aircraft
wind tunnel tests had shown that
effective aerosols could be produced
by discharging the bw agent into a high
velocity air stream
to confirm the wind tunnel test data an
aerial mission was conducted using a bw
incapacitating agent
flying at subsonic speed the f-100
disseminated the liquid agent along a
15-mile line upwind of the test grid
data from these tests were used to
determine the effective coverage that
could be expected with an operational
type spray system employing the basic
principles of the experimental device
this study showed that one fighter
aircraft flying on the deck and
dispensing two wing tanks of a liquid bw
agent would cause infection in more than
50 percent of the populace in an area
125 miles long by 30 miles deep
three large aircraft could release
sufficient agent to infect over 50
percent of the people
in an area equivalent to a belt 140
miles wide
extending from new york to chicago
comparable to the total area of
pennsylvania ohio and indiana
volunteers and test animals were exposed
in the field to a mildly incapacitating
bw agent
aerosol generators were located on the
line several thousand feet upwind from
the groups of men and animals
when preparations were complete the
generators were fired
even though the volunteers could not see
taste or smell the aerosol as it drifted
by
they later developed symptoms typical of
the disease as a result of inhaling the
infectious organisms
as each subject developed the
characteristic fever therapy was
instituted
all responded to treatment and recovered
completely
this laboratory test
demonstrates the casualty effect of a
non-persistent nerve gas developed by
the united states army chemical warfare
laboratories
a healthy rabbit is placed in a sealed
chamber containing a small amount of the
toxic gas
the clock timer on the wall indicates
the number of seconds the animal has
been exposed to the gas
the chemical agent rapidly begins to
take effect
and in 55 seconds the animal is
incapacitated
the amount of gas used in this test was
equivalent to only one drop of the
chemical in liquid form
the chemical acts on the nervous system
and causes respiratory failure
death occurred after the animal had been
exposed to the gas for two minutes and
fifteen seconds
in the field goats have been exposed to
concentrations of the agent from a gas
field artillery shell
the test animals were placed in a trench
to protect them from the fragmentation
and blast effects of the artillery round
one of the goats had been fitted with a
protective mask
a 155 millimeter howitzer mounted on a
tower was aimed at the center of the
circular target area
after the howitzer had been loaded and
test personnel had retreated to a safe
distance
the weapon was fired by remote control
one minute after the shell exploded
the animals were incapacitated by the
effects of the gas
some of the animals were dead after five
minutes
and within 15 minutes all had expired
except the goat having the mask
similar field tests were made with
animals placed inside a tank
here again one of the goats was
protected with a mask
in contrast to the earlier test
a gas shell of small caliber was used
and the amount of agent released was of
course much less
five minutes after the shell detonated
against the tank
the unmasked animals were dead from the
effects of the gas
this test is an example of how toxic gas
can be used to penetrate enclosed places
and attack personnel protected in hard
targets
the destructive action of the nerve
gases can be illustrated by a few simple
sketches
this represents a normal nerve ending
and this
a normal muscle
the transmission of an impulse from the
nerve ending to the muscle
involves the liberation of tiny
quantities of a chemical called
acetylcholine which triggers a muscle
action
after a nerve directed muscle
contraction
the enzyme cholinesterase almost
immediately inactivates the
acetylcholine
permitting the muscle to relax again
and thus the muscle action is terminated
nerve gases knock out cholinesterase
allowing an excess of acetylcholine to
accumulate
as a result
the stimulation to muscle action by
acetylcholine becomes uncontrolled
and the neutralizing or relaxing effect
of cholinesterase
becomes less and less
depending upon the severity of the nerve
gas exposure
the drug atropine
long used in medicine as a
pre-anaesthetic agent
can block the effects of accumulated
acetylcholine
and thereby help to control muscle
stimulation
thus
atropine can prevent the destructive
action of nerve gases
the psycho chemicals or k agents being
developed by the chemical core
comprise a new family of incapacitating
agents
these non-lethal chemicals have an
astonishing capacity to cause abnormal
behavior in man and animals
in laboratory experiments a normal cat
displays the typical hunter instinct
toward a mouse
minute quantity of lysergic acid
diethylamide
lsd
is administered in aerosol form
this chemical begins to react on the
brain
and after 45 seconds
the effects of the psycho chemical
become apparent
the cat is no longer interested in
catching the mouse
and in fact appears to be afraid of it
just a small quantity of lsd
is sufficient to upset the normal
physical and emotional behavior pattern
to observe the effects of the
psychochemical on humans
enlisted volunteers were asked to take
part in a carefully controlled test
prior to the test the men behaved in a
well-disciplined manner responding
promptly to commands and executing
movements with
precision during a break
each of the volunteers except the drill
sergeant
received a minute dose of the psycho
chemical in coffee
and about 30 minutes later the squad was
ordered to fall in
now the response of the men is entirely
different
they have ceased to be alert but have
become relaxed and carefree
they cannot control the impulse to laugh
and they no longer behave like
well-disciplined troops
the drill sergeant has not received any
of the psycho-chemical
and he issues commands as before
but the response of the men is sluggish
and their movements ragged
they have become confused irrational and
uncontrollable
seeing the effects of this chemical
compound
it is not difficult to imagine the habit
that could be created
among weapons crews and command
headquarters in time of war
in the continuing search for
incapacitating agents
the chemical warfare laboratories are
investigating a great many chemical
compounds
one of these
cs4640
is a particular interest as a potential
incapacitator
a very small amount of this compound
produces partial paralysis in laboratory
animals
the amount required is indicated in this
comparison with an ordinary aspirin
tablet
the two dogs to be used in this test
have been exposed to effective doses of
the chemical in previous tests and have
always recovered completely
a dilute solution of
cs4640 is prepared for use in creating
an aerosol of the chemical
in an exposure chamber
although exposure to the aerosol for
about 30 seconds
is sufficient for the chemical to take
effect
in this test
the dogs will breathe the aerosol
for one minute
exposure began at 0 900 hours
in numerous experiments temporary
paralysis has been produced in a variety
of laboratory animals mice rats guinea
pigs rabbits cats dogs
goats and monkeys
after one minute the dogs were removed
from the exposure chamber
on animals the effect of a small dose of
cs4640
is similar to that of a very much larger
dose of morphine
it paralyzes the skeletal muscles
depending on the size of the dose in
relation to the weight of the animal the
paralysis can be made to last from one
to several hours
about 10 minutes after the chemical had
taken full effect
the black dog was given an injection of
an antidote
a couple of minutes later
the paralysis had disappeared
and the black dog was normal again
without treatment the other dog remained
paralyzed
the paralysis produced by the exposure
to cs4640
for one minute
lasted one hour
after which
the brown dog recovered
this incapacitating chemical compound is
still in the research stage
and no data are yet available as to its
effects on humans
against the effects of toxic chemicals
the protective mask has always been the
most important piece of individual
equipment
it fully protects the delicate
respiratory tract
but there are several chemical agents
which have a percutaneous effect
by absorption through the skin they can
cause casualties or even death
nerve gases are so toxic that a very
small amount of the liquid in contact
with the skin can have a casualty effect
for these the protective mask alone is
not sufficient
the whole body must be protected with
combat clothing which has been specially
treated
after exposure to chemical attack
even though protective clothing and
masks are worn
further precautionary action may be
necessary to prevent casualties
for this purpose an individual
decontamination and treatment kit e-21
has been developed
a dusting bag contains a decontaminating
chemical and a small capsule of agent
indicating dye
by crushing and kneading the capsule is
broken and the dye indicator is
intimately mixed with the dusting powder
the decontaminating powder will
neutralize small droplets and aerosols
of nerve gas
at the same time the presence of larger
drops will be quickly revealed by a
color change of the dye indicator
small metal patches are provided to seal
off these spots of gross contamination
so as to prevent any possibility of the
nerve gas penetrating through the
clothing to the skin
the decontaminant is also applied to
pieces of individual equipment
to prevent secondary contamination which
might result from handling the equipment
plotting claws are provided for removing
any of the liquid agent which may have
splashed on the skin
the affected skin area is then swabbed
with a small bag of decontaminating
material which has been moistened with
water
the e-21 kit can be used to
decontaminate mustard as well as the
nerve gases
it is scheduled to undergo final
engineering tests in the fourth quarter
of fy 60.
no change has been made in the method of
impregnating outer garments of
protective clothing but the protective
underwear has been vastly improved over
the world war ii type which was
uncomfortable to wear and often cause
skin irritation
developed in coordination with the
quartermaster research and development
center
it is a soft textured lightweight cotton
fabric treated with high car
and gives good protection against liquid
toxic agents
its protective property is not
diminished by perspiration or laundering
and therefore does not require
re-impregnation
as was the case with the older type
the newly standardized field protective
mask m17 is much improved over older
types
vision and voice transmission are better
and having no external canister it is
streamlined and more comfortable to wear
new special purpose masks have also been
developed
for the helicopter pilot is the e 75
mask
which provides unrestricted vision and
is fitted with a special dynamic
microphone for aircraft radio
communication
of similar design is a special mask for
armored personnel
with an added feature for the comfort
and efficiency of the tank crew
provision is made for connecting the
individual's canister
to a large central canister in the tank
while operating the tank air is supplied
under pressure from the large canister
to the mask of each crew member
and breathing becomes effortless
a quick release connection permits the
crew to bail out rapidly without loss of
mass protection
still another type of special mask has
been developed for the casualty who is
unable to wear his m17 mask because of
head wounds
bag like in shape it is made of filter
material and equipped with clear plastic
eye pieces
a gas tight seal is formed by means of a
drawstring which maintains moderate
pressure around the neck
thus the patient is protected while
being moved through a toxic atmosphere
to an aid station or hospital
point source alarms have been developed
to detect and automatically warn of the
presence of nerve type chemical agents
which in vapor or aerosol form are
odorless and invisible
the larger model on the right has been
adopted by the united states navy for
shipboard use
the smaller model is a later development
which carries its own power source
these alarms continuously sample the
atmosphere through a chemically treated
paper
a concentration of toxic agent in the
air well below the level required to
cause casualties produces a color change
on the paper
this is detected by a photoelectric cell
activating the alarm system
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation is a newly
developed technique of artificial
respiration
in addition to medication nerve gas
casualties often may require aid in
breathing
with one hand the operator raises the
patient's chin to open up his throat and
upper airway
with the other hand she holds his nose
closed
then she takes a deep breath and
inflates his lungs just like blowing up
a balloon
the gauge at the upper right registers
the percent oxygen saturation of the
blood as measured by an ear oximeter
note how it falls off when the worker
stops the treatment
this patient is quite incapable of
breathing by himself
and without artificial respiration the
oxygen saturation of his blood soon
drops to a low level
when the treatment is resumed the
oximeter reading rapidly returns to
normal
the basic scientific groundwork for
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation was
performed by the chemical warfare
laboratories and the clinical research
was conducted under the auspices of the
army medical service at baltimore city
hospital
it is expected that this method of
artificial respiration will be adopted
by the armed forces
you